maurepas fait une nouvelle fois face à
l'arrivée de migrants dans sa commune
après avoir reçu une centaine de
personnes en juillet dernier au gymnase
des baissière la ville est obligé
d'accueillir à partir de ce vendredi 4
novembre 99 migrants principalement
venus d'iran et d'afghanistan
cette décision imposée par l'état fait
suite au démantèlement du camp de la
villette à paris
il s'agissait d'accueillir pour des
raisons de fraternité républicaine des
gens en souffrance
logés dans des conditions inadmissibles
dans un premier temps la mairie de
maurepas décidé de s'opposer cette
arrivée en manifestant devant le gymnase
des baissière je suis très en colère
parce que maurepas a déjà rempli son
devoir d'humanité pour accueillir des
débits grand l'été dernier au gymnase
des baissière et une seconde fois l'état
réquisitionne ce bâtiment en pleine
année scolaire
je ne comprends pas je ne comprends pas
pourquoi sur les 262 communes des
yvelines en tout cas sur le permet de 50
en ville c'est encore maurepas qui a été
choisi
après une heure de négociations un
compromis a été trouvé entre la
préfecture et la ville pour installer
les migrants dans la salle des fêtes
c'est une une alternative donc j'ai fait
un pas vers l'état pour éviter justement
de pénaliser les morlaisiens avec la
suppression pure et simple de 15 jours
d'activités sportives dans un gymnase
qui est extrêmement utilisez donc elle
l'état accepté cette solution et je m'en
réjouis
malgré tout maintenant je me pose des
questions quand même pour l'avenir pour
éviter que ça se reproduise
abbas est tellement déçu puisque
l'hébergement d'urgence de gens en
difficulté va être assurée c'est un
objectif et avec l'accord du maire
les migrants devraient rester jusqu'au
18 novembre dans la salle des fêtes de
bord passe selon les dernières
informations communiquées par la
préfecture
ils pourraient être jusqu'à 350 dans les
ibid